[Music]
what do the minimalists think about the
war in ukraine
here's what i'll say
it doesn't matter what ryan and i think
about like what are your beliefs what if
i say oh it's great
when is that going to get you right
here's what it's going to do you're
going to say oh well that's a weird
stance to have and now i disagree with
you now i no longer approve of josh or
ryan or both of you right i don't
approve of tk so i can turn this podcast
off or i can stop falling or
i want you to believe exactly like me
and so if josh says you know what i
think the war in ukraine is awful i
think all wars are terrible but
especially this war in ukraine
and uh that is my personal belief i
think all war is terrible yeah i think
all war is a by-product of unenlightened
people no enlightened person would ever
go to war now that's not a very
practical thing they're not actionable
right well putin were just to become
more enlightened i was uh driving here
this morning
and there's a bike shop near my house
and there was this beautiful
sort of
bumper sticker it was a window sign in
the bike shop and it said
fight putin
ride a bike
and there's a whole world in those five
words right
because it signals a few things on the
surface it tells you like who they
support or whatever right i support the
current thing right but they do so in a
playful creative way
that says hey here's my stance but also
like here's something that you can do
with your personal life so you're not as
dependent on oil or foreign countries or
yeah
fossil fuels etc right but then there's
also some other thing that's part of
that and it's like hey enjoy this type
of consumerism
um
we're going to use this
war to sell you a bike
it is another spin an uncharitable spin
that i could put on that now either way
i'm simply ascribing an attention on to
them judgment is but a mirror and i am
now judging them i'm holding up the
mirror and saying
well
and even this like say we were to take
this clip
from the private podcast cut it out put
it up on youtube we don't run any ads
but think of how we could profit if we
turned on the ads on our youtube channel
now we could pro two could profit from
the war in ukraine by putting up some
sort of title what do the minimalists
think about the war in ukraine yeah and
now
we are running ads against that we're
making money off or you could even argue
hey we encourage people to sign up for
our patreon we're doing this whole
political clutter episode
uh this week and so we're doing a long
form pl and if you
we we put up the right you worn ukraine
title
now i'm using the war in ukraine to sell
you something i don't want that and so
i'll tell you this don't if this does
end up uh jordan being a a standalone
youtube club don't sign up for our
patreon on the basis of this there are
much better reasons to do that but
certainly has nothing to do with the war
in
ukraine
i will say this though as war being a
byproduct of unenlightened people the
solution isn't for everyone to become
enlightened
the solution if there is one is
understanding
and what i mean by that so
yes there is a war going on right now
they're actually in fact there are 23
wars they have more than a thousand
deaths that are currently going on right
now and this is not some form of what
about ism
it's understanding that the media
gives us
salacious news in order to aggregate our
eyeballs onto their television show
their newspaper their website
so they can place ads in front of us and
so the more salacious the more
click-baity the headline the more ads
they can serve up to us so they use
things like the war
if and only if
it gets your eyeballs onto it why aren't
you hearing about the war in darfur or
what about south sudan now part of
that's just because they're old and
maybe there's a lack of nuclear weapons
exactly but the biggest reason you're
not hearing about it the only reason
you're not hearing about it is it
doesn't get eyeballs under their product
because if the war in south sudan
got eyeballs onto the new york times
they would lead with that every single
day it'd be above the fold it'd be front
page it'd be it would be on the website
first thing you saw
because then they could serve more
advertisements to you so understand that
sometimes the
the reason that we're paying attention
to whatever we're paying attention to is
because it serves someone else
it's not serving us
yeah like what we call the news is a
matter of curation like every single day
there are more people who like get
murdered or come up missing or die to a
tragic accident then we literally have
the time to talk about
and so what makes the news
of all the people who die
of all the people who go missing who get
murdered who suffer
what determines the people that we talk
about on the news well
what's good for business
you know who's going to be more
interesting who's going to generate the
more clicks and it's such a dangerous
thing
to define what it means to be informed
based on someone else's process of
profit driven curation
we have to
be a part of the news by
finding our own sources of information
that allow us to say
i'm gonna study the world and understand
the place that i live in according to
the things that i think are important
right like lots of people die today we
can't talk about them all which ones do
i want to focus on and do i want to
focus on any today like but that's
really hard you know terence mckenna has
this uh excellent clip i encourage
everybody to watch on youtube maybe we
can share in the links it's called uh
create your own road show
he's like you know turn off the
television
close the magazines forget about npr
forget about the newspaper create your
own show your own roadshow you know what
are your hopes what are your fears
what are your dreams
your orgasms all of those types of
things right what's going on in your
world and what matters to you oh but
that's selfish
and when people say that what that
really means is like i don't like you
focusing on what's important to you i
want you to stop being selfish and focus
on what's important to me
which is the most selfish thing i need
you to contort your world view to adhere
to mine yeah ryan what are your orgasms
so many different things oh man i uh
i think people
they worry about the war they worry
about voting
a lot of it's out of fear like i'm
certainly fearful of a nuclear attack i
mean that's why i started paying
attention to the war um
but yeah i mean where's bad injury like
i feel compassion for
anybody who's like suffering during this
war but
you know it's interesting because we
live we're lucky i don't even know if i
call it a privilege because privilege
the only reason you you the only way you
can get to that word and and put that
label on someone is if you're comparing
them to someone else so if you're not
comparing then there really is things
just are it's not good or bad it's not a
privilege or not a privilege it just is
but in this country you could call it a
privilege i guess
but we have the ability to to not be
oppressed as other countries and because
there's this lack of oppression we have
this free will this free reign that
allow us to care about the dumbest
things i'm not calling the war dumb i'm
not calling about you know i'm not
talking about that but i'm talking about
the things that come up
in the media it's like some of these
things really don't matter at all but
they only matter to us because we don't
have bigger problems than these little
things these little problems that we
make a big deal about and i think that
for me is important to recognize that
like yeah i might get mad
over a certain issue like i really don't
want to bring anything up um
because i don't want to distract from
our conversation but you know you don't
want to clutter it with yeah with
political clutter exactly but there
might be an issue that comes up and i'm
like oh i can't believe that that person
said that thing or either promoting this
and they should be promoting that and
then but i have to take a step back and
be like
wow like i'm really lucky to have to
care about this
you know yeah and not only do all three
of us have different political beliefs
or non-beliefs right but we also have
different religious beliefs and so i'm
gonna turn to tk for a second here you
know my favorite uh
bible verse is father forgive them for
they know not what they do
and that has helped me so many times if
someone gets outraged at me for
something i've done or said
hey sometimes i don't know what i've
been doing for sure right
but when they have a reaction that
doesn't really comport
onto
[Music]
reality forgive them for they know not
what they do whether they're treating me
a particular way
if they're lashing out and anger or fear
or whatever it might be but what's the
uh the serenity prayer can you walk me
through that because i have an exercise
i want to walk the listener through
oh man um i don't know if i have it by
uh have it like
if i can directly quote it as kind of a
paraphrase but it it's something to the
effect of um
grant me the um
what serenity to the serenity to accept
the things that i cannot change
the um
what are the courage to change the
things that i can yeah and the reason to
know the difference yeah yeah and so
here's here's the way that i look at
news whether it's the war in ukraine or
it is
an article about kylie jenner right
take a piece of paper
make a list of everything that you're
worried about
the war
the
starvation
whatever it is the bathrooms people are
using yes
everything that you're worried about an
entire list
and then go in and apply the serenity
prayer to it cross off everything
that's outside of your control
and then focus
on the things
that are in your control so to recap
take a piece of paper
write down everything that you're
worried about
the wars the celebrity gossip what
you're going to have for dinner
everything you're worried about
cross out the things now that are
outside of your control
and then focus on
the things that are in your control um
we have a question here to have
something to that real quick yeah uh
malcolm x says of all our studies
history most rewards our research
i think there is great value in
consuming things
that were not created in your lifetime
because it gives you a different sense
of time and a broader sense of
perspective about the world that you
live in one of the things we
underestimate about attention today is
that our concept of what is important is
so easily manipulated it literally
changes every day and our concept of
what we need to pay attention to is
often based on what is screaming the
loudest or what is shining the brightest
and we have so little control over
what's screaming the loudest and what's
shining the brightest and it's very
difficult in the moment to be able to
evaluate the things that are being
talked about in terms of big history
right will this matter in 10 years will
this even matter in 10 minutes think
about all the things that perhaps we
felt a lot of emotions about a year ago
that we never talk about anymore when
you study history it improves your
ability to get a feel for the things
that stand the test of time because when
you look at history there were lots of
day-to-day fads and day-to-day trends
that just got buried in irrelevance but
there were other broader themes and
issues and questions and problems that
just never went away or that had a
bigger impact on society and so i think
history is so important and so
when you make a list of things like all
right
kylie jenner or you know uh the the uh
you know the the johnny depp case or any
of that kind of stuff it's like all
right
add to that list
something has nothing to do with your
lifetime it can be
william
shakespeare james baldwin
i can be it could be anything that just
didn't happen in your lifetime and ask
yourself
why are the first two things on that
list
more worthy to be called news or
important than the last couple of things
on that list merely because they're
happening now
merely because they're being talked
about today
if if that's your answer then you might
be suffering from recency bias you might
be suffering from manipulation of people
who are experts people who are the best
in the world
at getting you to click on something
rather than something that preceded
those people's very existence i think
history is a great antidote did you
enjoy this stand-alone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free